you know I guess very early on I asked
myself you know what do we really do at
my company so just so you understand
O'Reilly Media started out as a tech
writing consulting firm then we became a
computer book publisher then we started
running technology conferences we
started an online ebook platform which
evolved into an online learning platform
which is really the heart of the
business today but we realized actually
in some work that we did with with with
Lawrence the Lawrence Wilkinson is
sitting here in the front row you know
we really started asking ourselves a lot
about who we want to be overall and in
this sort of period of investigation we
really started to think of ourselves as
a technology transfer company at heart
that our business was fundamentally
changing the world by spreading the
knowledge of innovators and we've tried
to you know live by that ever since and
our you know are sort of our motto what
the company is create more value than
you capture which came out of a
management retreat again about that time
about 2000 when I was telling the story
to my executive team of an internet
billionaire who will remain nameless
who'd said he'd started his company
within a riley book and I said yes great
you know he got billions and we got 30
bucks seems like a good trade you know
because we really like using the service
that he built you know it's like you
know we got 30 bucks but we also got
this amazing you know service so well it
is fun and anyway then Brian Irwin who
was my VP of Marketing said yeah we
create more value than we capture and
then we started making that as a a motto
you
[Music]